MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Craig!
I had a great time playing
board games last night.
Which reminds me, I've recently
completed a top-secret side
project, a web app to track
each player's performance
and win rates over time
for bragging rights.
CRAIG LABENZ: Ooh,
bragging rights.
I love bragging.
But say, what did you use
to build this web app?
MARTIN OMANDER: So lately
I've been using Django
for my web apps' back ends.
But deploying Django
isn't always easy.
CRAIG LABENZ:
Martin, when I say--
I feel you on that.
But luckily I've been
working on a Terraform script
to automate the
entire process on GCP.
Want to test it out
on your project?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that would be amazing!
Show me the way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CRAIG LABENZ: I've been
using and deploying
Django for over a decade.
And honestly, it's
tricky every time.
MARTIN OMANDER: That
makes me feel better,
to hear you say that.
There are a lot of tedious
parts to get right.
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah,
there sure are.
You need a database, a web
server that ideally scales,
storage for static
files and media,
and encrypted
application secrets.
It's not easy to
get all that right.
Now, Cloud Run is serverless, so
it can handle the scaling part.
But the rest are
still a challenge.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
your script handles
all of that, including
application secrets?
How is that even possible?
CRAIG LABENZ: It's
possible by the magic of,
we'll probably have
to make a few edits
to your settings.py file.
But I've been using it on my
own web apps for a bit now.
Here, let me run it real quick
to redeploy my application,
and then we can integrate
it into your project.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds great.
Oh, look, there it goes.
Wow.
You and I just stood
here like bumps on a log
while the script did everything.
CRAIG LABENZ: I know.
Wasn't it great?
I'll send you the link
to the repository.
And after you clone it,
you can walk through it.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
I have the code up.
I've seen a little Terraform
before, but I'm not an expert.
What am I looking at here?
CRAIG LABENZ: Terraform
is an open-source
infrastructure-as-code
tool that allows
for consistent,
declarative workflows
to manage large-scale
application infrastructure.
That's a bit of a mouthful.
But in short, it
just means you get
to write down what servers
your application needs
and how they should
connect to each other.
And Terraform figures out
how to make that a reality.
MARTIN OMANDER: And it knows
how to talk with Google Cloud?
CRAIG LABENZ: It sure does.
Looking up at the
top of the file,
the first block specifies a
dependency on the Google Cloud
platform bindings.
So with that, Terraform
downloads the necessary code
to translate everything
that we write here
into Google Cloud API calls.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
OK, I'm hooked.
Can you walk me
through this file?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah.
So the next step-- make
environment variables
locally accessible to
your Terraform workflow.
You can hard-code
anything that's
fixed to be default
values and then leave
the rest to be passed in
from the command line.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
that makes sense.
And what does the
script do next?
CRAIG LABENZ: If you've ever
configured a new GCP project
by hand in the Web
Console, you've
encountered the process of
activating specific service
APIs.
So this next part looks
ahead of the complete set
of service APIs it will
require and turns them all on.
We'll also want to set up
a custom service account
to run our Cloud Run service.
The default service account has
access to do a lot of things.
So I usually create
my own service account
and specifically set what
it can and cannot do.
MARTIN OMANDER: I love
that this script even
captures the principle
of least privilege.
CRAIG LABENZ: Always.
Now, the next step
takes some time
to complete the first time
you run this configuration,
because it initializes an entire
Cloud SQL Postgres instance.
MARTIN OMANDER:
This section looks
like it does a lot
of heavy lifting
I see the creation of
a Cloud SQL instance--
let's see, a user, and
a specific password.
But how do we get that
password into our code?
CRAIG LABENZ: Hold
on to that thought,
because it is coming soon.
But first, there's
a section that
sets up the final
project-specific values we
have, our admin user's password
and a Google Cloud Storage
bucket to host our
static and media files.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, neat.
I like that Terraform
generates these secrets,
so they never
exist in plaintext.
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah, exactly.
And now that Terraform has
generated everything sensitive,
we can prepare to securely
get all of that information
into our Django settings.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, that
one is a little dense.
Can you walk me
through it, Craig?
CRAIG LABENZ: Absolutely.
This block uses a simple
template, which I'll send you,
to create an
environment variable
file with our database
credentials, secret key,
and storage bucket.
Later, we'll make an edit
to your settings.py file
to actually read
in those values.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Perfect, because I
have flagged some
to-dos in my settings
file for each of those things.
What's next here?
CRAIG LABENZ: So far,
we've generated values
for a few sensitive
pieces of our app.
But Terraform has
yet to actually share
that information with anyone.
So this part creates a new
entry in Secret Manager
and gives access to the
necessary service accounts.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see
this creating new secrets.
But have our secret values been
uploaded to Secret Manager yet?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yes, good eye.
If our Terraform
manifest ended here,
we would, in fact, have some
empty and pretty useless
entries in Secret Manager.
But that's where this
next part comes in,
to gather up all of the
values we care about
and populate those secrets.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
And I'm guessing that
our Django app will then
need to access these
secrets during startup?
CRAIG LABENZ: You're really
quite a good guesser, Martin.
Has anyone ever told you that?
MARTIN OMANDER: Aw, shucks.
CRAIG LABENZ: So this is where
that template file comes in,
because the structure of
the secrets that we uploaded
isn't just the values awkwardly
placed in the text file,
but instead are valid
environment variables file
that our application can source,
thus allowing your Django
code to pull those values
right out of the environment.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
Terraform's thought
of everything.
And now we're getting to the
Cloud Run service definition.
CRAIG LABENZ: Indeed.
It's taken a lot to get here,
but the Terraform manifest
is now finally ready to define
our actual Cloud Run service.
MARTIN OMANDER: I also see
another IAM setting there?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah.
There's always more IAM setting.
In the Google Cloud Console,
there's a checkbox that says,
"Make this service public."
And the GCloud CLI, it's the
--allow-unauthenticated flag.
In short, these two
just open up our service
to the entire internet, which
is, of course, what we want.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
speaking of policy, it
looks like you're also
setting service permissions.
And is that a for loop?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah, it is.
Terraform allows you
to perform actions
against a list of values.
In this case, we're
giving both Cloud Build
and our actual Django service
account access to Cloud Run
and to Cloud SQL.
MARTIN OMANDER: But why
does Cloud Build need access
to the database?
CRAIG LABENZ: Well,
that's a good question.
As most Django developers
know, some of your deployments
involve schema migrations
that must be applied
running manage.py migrate.
The only problem is,
Cloud Run has nowhere
to run that one-off command.
So to solve this, I've
set up a series of steps
in the cloudbuild-migrate.yaml
script to run against
our container image.
One of these is the
famous migrate command.
And thus Cloud Build, will also
require access to the database.
MARTIN OMANDER: So is that
your continuous delivery
configuration?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah, it is.
And you can run this manually
or as part of a deployment
to automatically run
the steps that you need
to migrate your application,
or any other commands
that you need.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
There's one last
part of the Terraform
script that we haven't covered,
these output parts here.
What are they?
CRAIG LABENZ: Those are
values that Terraform
will display once it's
finished applying everything.
And these are the useful
values that we need,
our service URL and
our superuser password.
Of course, we've defined our
password as being sensitive,
so it will only output that
if we explicitly ask for it.
We could get those values
by running GCloud commands
against Cloud Run
and Secret Manager,
but this saves some time.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
This is all so declarative.
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah,
that's the point.
Terraform allows you to
capture your entire deployment
process in one
declarative manifest,
and it handles the rest.
MARTIN OMANDER: Now, all that
mumbo-jumbo about consistent,
declarative infrastructure
really makes sense.
So with all this, I can go
edit my settings.py file now.
CRAIG LABENZ: Sure can.
Open up that file, and
we'll get started editing.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, I'm
in my settings.py file,
and I'm ready to grab my
passwords from Secret Manager.
CRAIG LABENZ: Great.
I'm sending you a
snippet now, which
you can drop in at the top of
your file, pretty much as is.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, this is hefty.
Let's see.
That read_env function will
read from a local environment,
plus a .Env file, if I have one.
But then we get
to this try block.
Let's see.
We attempt to use the Google
Auth API to load our default
credentials in production.
I know these are provided
by Cloud Run itself.
If they're missing, we must
be doing local development,
so it quietly fails?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yep, you're
on the right track.
This setup handles
both production
and local development,
which is nice.
MARTIN OMANDER: And then, if
it sees we have a project ID,
we use the Secret Manager API
to get those very same secrets
we saved in Terraform manifest.
And then, with those values, it
loads them into the environment
as well?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah, precisely.
And instead of accessing those
variables via os.environ,
like you might be used
to, I do recommend
using the environment library
to streamline the process.
MARTIN OMANDER:
This sounds amazing.
Let me quickly edit
my settings.py file
in the other locations to read
in all of our secret values.
First, I'll update
my secret key.
Then I'll let the
environment package handle
all of my database settings.
And lastly, I'll read in the
correct static files bucket.
OK, so Craig, you're telling me
that if I run this script now,
it will deploy my app?
This task that I usually spend
an entire day suffering through
will be just done?
CRAIG LABENZ: Almost.
Open up that readme, and
you'll see a few extra commands
that we have to run the first
time we deploy our project.
MARTIN OMANDER:
OK, opening it now.
All right.
I'm setting the
$PROJECT_ID variable
and activating it
with the GCloud CLI.
I'm already authenticated
with my project.
Otherwise, I would need to run
GCloud Auth application default
login.
Enabling a few basic
services, I see.
I imagine this simplified the
Terraform manifest in some way.
Next up is gcloud builds submit.
I know this one.
It actually reads my Docker file
and uploads the resulting image
to Google Container Registry.
Oh, and here we go, terraforming
it and terraform apply.
Whoa!
Look at it go.
Things are moving
pretty fast, except--
oh, yeah.
You said the database would
take a while to initialize?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah.
While that's working, want
to see something neat?
Open up this project in
the Google Cloud Console,
and you'll see this database
initializing exactly
as if you'd just gone through
the Create Cloud SQL instance
wizard.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right!
Look at that database
being created.
Like you said, this
can take a while.
See you back here
in five minutes?
CRAIG LABENZ: Sounds good.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
The Terraform script
finished successfully.
And look, just
like you said, it's
printed my Cloud
Run Services URL.
But first I have one more first
deployment command to run.
CRAIG LABENZ: Yep.
But you'll actually run
this command any time
you deploy a change that
alters your static files
or your database schema.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
now, the last step--
we output the URL and
check that it worked.
Oh, my gosh!
I can hardly believe it!
CRAIG LABENZ: Pretty neat, eh?
And now let me show you
something else cool.
Run terraform apply again.
MARTIN OMANDER: But Craig,
I don't need two instances
of my app deployed.
CRAIG LABENZ: No, of course not.
But trust me.
Run the command again
and see what happens.
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, you've
never led me wrong before.
So here we go.
CRAIG LABENZ: See?
It detected that everything
you declared already exists,
so the whole
process did nothing.
And now, moving
forward, you can run
that command whatever you want.
In each pass, it will only
do something if you just
changed the Terraform manifest.
MARTIN OMANDER: Craig, I
honestly can't believe it.
With this Terraform script, I
can deploy my entire Django app
to Cloud Run in no time.
This usually eats up
my entire Saturday.
CRAIG LABENZ: Happy
to help, Martin.
But say, maybe next
time as a thank-you,
when we're playing Catan, you
cannot play such hardball with
me when I propose
resource trades.
MARTIN OMANDER: You
can't just expect
me to offer you buy one,
get one on my lumber
whenever you need it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]